alors vous l'avez trouvé sincère dans
ces excuses au niveau livre absolument
pas moi je vous dis honnêtement moi je
pense qu'il est surtout en train de
rentrer en campagne il essaie de tout
mettre derrière d'essayer de caresser
les gens dans le sens du poil
qu'il avait été sincère en 5 ans il
aurait fait autre chose que ce qu'on a
vu là moi j'ai vu bien trop rapprocher
au président mais il y a eu aucune
raison aucune voteriez jamais pour lui
ah non jamais de la vie jamais voté
comment c'est pour qui vous allez voter
malheureusement pas encore encore je le
souhaiterais de le répéter je suis en
train d'essayer de réunir toutes ces
listes citoyennes pour avoir un candidat
ça coûte du peuple c'est compliqué c'est
très bien mais s'il y a pas mais je
pense que là jusqu'au bout là olive
olive c'est vrai qu'on arrive
votre personne n'a grâce à vous moi je
veux plus de politique politicienne qui
est pas à l'écoute des Français je veux
vraiment retrouver une politique
citoyenne vraiment pour les Français et
à l'écoute des Français je veux qu'il y
a un monde où le référendum
le moins pire pour vous le moins pire
comment il s'appelle
vous pouvez les retrouver Philippe poto
Philippe Poutou français
au jour d'aujourd'hui s'il y a que ça je
voudrais blanc d'accord j'espère qu'on
va arriver à ramener un conte un
candidat citoyen honnêtement alors il
est revenu également le président sur la
photo avec ses jeunes à Saint-Martin
dans les Antilles où l'on voyait un
jeune faire un doigt d'honneur regardez
si il a répondu la photo de Saint-Martin
avec le jeune et et alors ça il faut
protéger la fonction par tempérament je
ne me protège pas un jeune m'interpelle
qui sortait de prison sa mère était chez
lui j'ai dit je vais aller voir votre
mère et ils ont fait des imbéciles oui
mais j'ai été suffisamment naïf pour
aller laisser faire cette photo donc
qu'est-ce que voulez-vous que je vous
dise je n'avais pas à exposer l'image de
la fonction à une époque qui n'est pas
non plus ni celle du général de Gaulle
ni celle de François Mitterrand
c'est-à-dire celle du selfie permanent
et des réseaux sociaux c'est aussi ça le
monde dans lequel
ça c'est pas mal
de réponse c'est maintenant il pouvait
pas prévoir que le mec allait faire un
doigt d'honneur à la caméra c'est quand
même un peu difficile c'est vrai que
c'est on peut pas le 150 milliards de
personnes qui font des selfies avec lui
dès qu'ils peuvent ils pouvaient pas
voilà et il explique à l'époque de
Gaulle s'il avait fait des selfies il
serait peut-être arrivé la même chose
c'est sûr mais bon moi ce qui m'a gêné
c'est que le président est resté dans sa
zone de confort et que lui soit dans la
communication c'est très bien mais je
trouve que les journalistes ont été trop
policés ils l'ont laissé dans une zone
de communication Audrey Crespo-Mara un
peu moins mais Darius Rocheman
excusez-moi il avait l'air content
d'être là ils sont allés en permanence
je trouve qu'il a été d'une faiblesse
extrême